so let's introduce ourselves to the
polynomial remainder theorem and as
we'll see it a little do you feel a
little magical at first but in future
videos we will prove it and we'll see
you well like like many things in
mathematics when you actually think it
through maybe it's not so much magic so
what is the polynomial remainder theorem
well it tells us that if we start with
some polynomial f of X so this right
over here is a polynomial polynomial and
we divide it we divide divided by X
minus a then the remainder then the
remainder from that essentially
polynomial long division is going to be
f of a it is going to be it is going to
be F of a F of a I know this might seem
a little bit abstract right now I'm
talking about f of X is and X minus a s
let's make it a little bit more concrete
so let's say that f of X f of X is equal
to I'm just gonna make up a I say a
second-degree polynomial this would be
true for any polynomial though so 3x
squared minus 4x plus 7 and let's say
that a is I don't know a is 1 so we're
gonna divide by we're gonna divide that
we're gonna divide by X minus X minus 1
so a in this case is equal to 1 so let's
just do the polynomial long division and
I encourage you to pause the video and
if you're not unfamiliar with polynomial
long division I encourage you to watch
that before watching this video because
I will assume you know how to do a
polynomial long division so divide 3x
squared minus 4x plus 7 divided by X
minus 1 see what you get is your
remainder and see if that remainder
really is f of 1
some of you mean you've had a go at it
so let's let's work through it together
so let's divide X minus 1 X minus 1 into
three x squared into three x squared
minus four X plus seven all right a
little bit of polynomial long division
is never a bad way to start your morning
night it's morning for me I don't know
anyone it is for you all right
so hi how many I'll look at I always
look at the X term here the highest
degree term and then I'll start with a
highest degree term here so how many
times does X go into three x squared
well it goes three x times 3x times X is
three x squared so I'll write three x
over here I'll try to get in the I guess
you could say the first degree place 3x
times X is 3x squared 3x times negative
1 is negative 3x and now we want to
subtract we want to subtract this thing
and this is just the way that you do
traditional long division and so what do
we get
well three x squared minus three x
squared that's just going to be zero so
these just add up to zero and this
negative 4x this is going to be plus 3x
right a negative of a negative negative
4x plus 3x is going to be is going to be
negative X so let me do this in a new
color so it's going to be negative
negative X and then we can bring down we
can bring down the 7 complete analogy to
how you first learn long division and
maybe I don't know third or fourth grade
so all I did is I multiplied three x
times this you get three x squared minus
three X and then I subtracted that from
three x squared minus four X to get this
right over here or you could say I
subtracted it from this whole from the
whole polynomial and then I got negative
x plus seven so now how many times does
X minus one go to negative x plus seven
well X goes into negative x negative one
times negative one times negative one
times X is negative x negative one times
negative one is positive one but then
we're gonna want to subtract this thing
we're gonna want to subtract this thing
and this is going to give us our
remainder so negative x minus negative x
that's the same thing as negative x plus
x so that's these are just going to add
up to 0 and then you have
seven this isn't gonna be seven plus one
remember you have this negative out so
if you distribute the negative this is
going to be a negative 1 7 minus 1 is 6
so your remainder here is 6 one way to
think about it you could say you could
say that you could say well actually
I'll save that for a future video this
right over here is the remainder
remainder and you know when you got to
the remainder and this is just all a
review of polynomial long division is
when you get something that has a lower
degree this is a I guess you could call
this a a zero degree polynomial this has
a lower degree than what you are
actually dividing into or then the X
minus one then you're devised or
so this is a lower degree so this is the
remainder you can't take this into this
anymore
any more times now by the polynomial
remainder theorem would if it's true and
I just picked a random example here this
is by no means of proof but just a kind
of a way to make it tangible of what the
polynomial remainder theorem is telling
us if there a polynomial remainder
theorem is true it's it's telling us
that f of a in this case 1 f of 1 should
be equal to 6 it should be equal to this
remainder now let's verify that this is
going to be equal to 3 times 1 squared
which is going to be 3 minus 4 times 1
so that's just going to be minus 4 plus
7 3 minus 4 is negative 1 plus 7 is
indeed is indeed we deserve a minor
drumroll is indeed equal to 6 so this is
just kind of at least for this
particular case we're saying okay it
seems like the polynomial remainder
theorem worked but the utility of it is
if someone said hey you know what's the
remainder if I were to divide 3x squared
minus 4x plus 7 by X minus 1 if all they
care about is a remainder they don't
care about the actual quotient all they
care about is the remainder you can say
hey look I can just take that you know
in this case a is 1 I can throw that in
I can evaluate F of 1 and I'm gonna get
6 I don't have to do all of this
business all I had would have to do is
this to figure out the remainder of 3x
squared when you take 3x squared minus
4x plus 7 and divide by
X minus 1